pending
home sales fell over 10 in february as
record load supply stifles the housing
market
article by cnbc okay housing markets
suffering its lowest supply and history
as spending home sales appending home
sales
a measure of signed contracts on as
existing homes fell wider than expected
10.6
in february compared to january there
were just one million three
one million thirty thousand homes for
sale at the end of february a 29 and a
half percent
drop compared with february 2020 that is
the largest annual decline
ever and the lowest supply on record
home priced above 250 000 have seen the
most active sales but home price about
500 000
to less than a million are starting to
see the same low inventory problems the
recent rise in mortgage rates
does not appear to be affecting home
buyer demand that much the average rate
on the 30-year
fixed loan started the year below three
percent and is now 3.45
it is still low historically speaking
home prices however have been climbing
quickly they are up more than 11 from a
year ago byron thoughts
well if you read that the first time i
read it yesterday it sounded like well
home sales are down and the real estate
market's down it's actually inventory
just purely inventory's down
which is driving prices up and what's
and so what happens is when there's tons
and tons of buyers
the existing inventory a normal natural
amount of people come to the market in
any given month and they
they decide it's time to sell their home
and they sell their home we talked a
little bit yesterday about new
home starts are huge lots of new homes
being built
the price of lumber uh got over a
thousand dollars
uh per thousand bucks the number
averaged 200 that's over there
it goes up for people to see it the
charges for the last 10 years or so that
in recent history it fluctuates between
200 and 400 it's just a commodity so in
other words bad time to build the house
well it's just an expensive time to
build a house yeah i mean it may not be
a bad time to build a house
i mean the materials are only the part
of the price of homelessness of of
building a home
of course the contractors as well are
charging more because again demand is
high so
look i mean that's insane by the way if
you look at the price of lumber that is
amazing
yeah so 2012 says 200 200
then it goes up 2013 to around 400 then
it goes back down in 2016 to 200
and it goes up to six hundred dollars in
2018 say
briefly briefly but back down to three
back down to 300
and then now it's a thousand dollars the
last six months
that's insane yeah it is it's okay so
bad time to build
just an expensive time for materials
that's that's it i mean it just is it's
not that much you know
everybody knows it if you try to buy a
house it's more than you thought it was
going to be and if you sell your house
it's worth more than you thought it
would
say that last point again please you
said it when you try to
build a house build or buy a house more
more than you thought it might be
and the home that you're about to sell
is actually more than you're going to
get more than you thought you would it's
a seller's market
is it completely selling your sellers if
you can sell
let me put it to you this way a guy says
i put my house on the market that
article that was going viral yesterday
guy puts a house on the market within
one day gets 65 cash offers
yeah i posted something yeah you put
that up he gets 65 cash offers
my ceo puts a house on a market within
24 hours he's got a bunch of cash offers
people aren't
and they ended up overpaying what the
value was sometimes the bidding work
the bidding war is going above what the
market is and people are selling today
with the following
contingent on the contract whether the
uh appraisal comes back or not it's
irrelevant you got to get the you got to
get the house so
say you buy the house for a million
dollars you make the upper million
dollars
seller accepts it okay appraisal comes
back at 900 000
you still have to buy it at a million
dollars that's what's happening
appraisals are typically triggered by a
mortgage you know
sellers sellers can play offense today
like never before
buyers you're in a sticky situation
right now adam what are your thoughts on
this well i've been very outspoken that
i
i'm not a real estate guy i don't uh it
all depends on your situation you're at
in life for instance i'm
um i rent and i pump all my money that i
make into
the stock market people say well you
gotta have exposure to real estate and
that's why i invest in reits
and i've invested into crypto and i've
definitely made some money on bitcoin
and all that fun stuff i just think that
owning a house is one of the more
overrated purchases you could ever make
uh and there's people gonna be out there
like what are you talking about you're
an idiot can i say something
i've been trying to tell you i'm gonna
blow my nose can you take the camera off
my face
like i don't know what other signals to
give you go ahead
all right so sorry everybody um
so my advice out there because i always
try to break things down you know
personal finance for the common person
out there
unless you got a family unless you got
kids unless you're going to be in the
same area for at least
five 10 years minimum just rent bro
you know what i think is the the
especially right now
with the sellers market what i think the
realtor association whoever did this the
best
marketing pr agenda they've ever done
ever was when they came out and they
said
renting is just throwing money away why
would you throw money away on rent
and i think it's a brilliant marketing
move but the reality is owning a home
i think it appreciates it three percent
annually stock market over time
it's between eight and ten percent uh
depending on inflation
so if you're single out there what's my
you know
what's your point if you're single out
there and you're just in your wealth
building phase you're just getting a
career and just kind of getting things
going
it's perfectly okay to rent perfectly
okay to rent
have a roommate split split whatever it
is do you have a differing opinion
but if you have a family i can
understand if you want to have a good
school zone and you know
people forget taxes mortgage yeah
maintenance like you said it's more
expensive than you thought
to build a house if you're not going to
be in there for a while certainly you
don't want to buy if you're going to be
gone in two years i mean
the the frictional cost of getting in
and getting out and the hassle of having
to get out
versus just walking around if people
don't know this and they just say i want
to buy a place i want to buy a place
well if you thought it no i just i think
i've got
it's time for me to buy but you have how
many houses that you own right now
uh houses um properties that you
personally own
um including my office five okay
and do you love being a landlord do you
love uh owning property or is it
more annoying than you thought it would
be give us a little insight
yes there are always things that you
hadn't anticipated certainly being a
landlord
i have a property that we rent but i
actually pay someone to do that
the other ones i don't i mean i am the
only tenant in the office building yeah
i own the office building and i own my
home i own a home in breckenridge
and i have a condo in sonoma so we don't
rent but they have one that i do
and uh so that's the only one that deal
with tenants and
it's it's it's definitely not a
guaranteed win
a lot of people think it is and there
are people that have made a lot of money
in real estate so people think well
this guy made a lot of money in real
estate so i want to be in real estate
and if i just buy real estate i'm going
to make money automatically and it's not
the case let me let me just say one
thing to that the people that i know who
have made
money money money in real estate this is
what they do
straight up this is what they do what's
that they do real estate they do
development they're
they have general contractors they've
got people that just when you do
development it's it's essentially
it's your product so you buy something
you sell it for more so you build up
you you buy a piece of land for a
hundred thousand dollars you put up a
strip center for five hundred thousand
dollars
and then you get it leased up and then
you sell it for a million two that mean
they're buying something they're
adding value and then they're selling it
for more or they're letting it run out
i wanna i wanna ask you a question
because you wrote an article years ago
what it was in the denver post am i yeah
correctly good memory and you were um i
mean i read the denver post religiously
yeah i mean it's the fifth one when i go
visit byron in breckenridge or an aspen
i
make sure to pick up a copy of the
denver post and this particular
article that i picked up was written by
none other than patrick bett david
talking about when you were in your
infancy stages of php you could have
bought a house and lived at you know at
a multi-million dollar house and done
that or
taken all your cash and started your
business which is obviously
100 x over the last decade whatever the
number is
but give us a little insight into that
article what you wrote what your mindset
was when you were building your company
for the average person buying a home
buying a home make makes sense
for the average person buying a home it
makes highlight average average persons
meaning i'm gonna stay in the same city
for the next 20 years i'm gonna
probably go to a job and do that for the
next 20 years i'm uh
going to make the stable not moving to
another state you have to realize i have
moved 11 times in the last 10 years
i have moved three states in the last
five years six years
just six years ago i was living in
california yeah then i lived in texas
for five years now i'm living in florida
i call people calling me telling me
how's texas i'm like i don't know i'm in
florida i couldn't tell you how texas is
you got out just in time
yeah and i got out just in time but the
point i'm trying to make to you is
i'm probably not the guy to i'm not a
fan of buying homes
for me it's a terrible idea for me to
buy homes that i'm living in
now at this point it's a different story
why
kids private schools kids got to go to
the same private it's unfair for you to
keep changing
where you live when you got a
five-year-old four-year-old a
seven-year-old a nine-year-old and they
keep having to make new friends and new
friends you can't create momentum
so you have to make a decision for them
as well where it's not like hey you're
gonna move again yeah to you may not be
a big deal but the two kid
it's too many moving parts like let
these kids settle down and build some
relationships
or else every school they go to they
kind of like well listen bro i'm having
a good time with you but we're probably
not going to be friends long term
because the last kid i became best
friends with 16 months later we left so
i can't get too close to you
so it becomes that one thing where you
have kids there's definitely other it
changes
for you why would you buy why why would
adam buy you're a butterfly why would
you buy there's no reason for you you
don't have a butterfly
you're a butterfly yeah have you ever
been called about a flight before
first time i called you one of them all
sorts of compliments believe me i'll get
crushed by the uh by the end of this
episode
but get back to that article where your
mindset was at when you were in my early
30s
i told my wife we were having a meeting
i'm in front of 66 guys when we started
php by the way shout out to php last
month was a record-breaking month with
congratulations 11
449 new business partners and we had
750 by the time everything's done new
licensed agents which is the third
biggest in america today most
highest newly licensed people with the
company will be us
in the month of march there's only two
that license more than us in the month
of march which is pretty exciting to see
what's going on policies will end up
being around 12 to 13 000 policies
but i gave a meeting in uh northridge
north balboa boulevard that was the
office okay northbridge down the street
from home depot my dad
loves going first thing my dad does when
he comes here he says hey pat i said
what that
take me to home depot i said i'm not
taking you to home depot i said why not
i said if i take you to home depot once
i have to take you every time i said i
want to show you where home depot is
yeah
it says okay okay so he went i said wait
i'm going to go if you want me to go to
home depot with you to carry some heavy
stuff i'll go with you i said what are
you buying he says one pipe cause i'm
not going home people
for a pipe here's the key your dad is
basically will ferrell in old school
i might go to home depot i don't know
it's gabriel the tank
frank the tank gabriel's a tank yeah so
so
you're in northridge i'm in northridge
i'm running the office i
start the company and i tell everybody
with my wife standing in the back i said
babe in the next five years i'm not
buying a house every penny i make i'm
putting it back into the business we're
going to rent
i said this publicly to everybody
we lived at a two bedroom apartment
complex at the summit
and then we went into a three-bedroom
house at encino
boulevard and then we went to chatswort
we had a few homes there and then we
made it out to dallas we moved like five
six times in california before we moved
out
but i put that money into business now
that may not be the story for everybody
the thing with buying homes it does it
not one story doesn't fit everyone's
you know narrative right it may work for
you it may not work for you may work for
me it may not work for kai but it
depends on where you're at for me and
ended up working out but going back to
the story here what's going on with real
estate
realtors can be bullies today here's
what realtors are using script you know
what realtor's script is today
look you don't have to make an offer
there's probably going to be five in the
next 24 hours
you don't have to make an offer so the
realtor of being the sweet realtor i
think this is a good investment for you
i think you ought to make the move
realtors today are saying don't make the
offer it's okay
we're going to get five offers the next
24 hours saying they can place them hard
so all
realtors are doing right now they have
one script you know what the script
is do you love this home because if you
love it
make the offer they can own it if you
make the offer don't play the game today
realtors have a lot of leverage today if
they have any homes to represent so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you